new york governor andrew cuomo who is
already facing criticism for part of his
response to the pandemic faces
new trouble this morning over detailed
allegations of inappropriate behavior in
the workplace
the latest accusations come from former
aide lindsey boyan who wrote
andrew cuomo abused his power as
governor to sexually harass me
just as he had done with so many other
women
mololengi is following this story for us
mola good morning to you what's the
governor saying about these allegations
oh good morning tony a spokesperson for
the governor said in a statement quote
claims of inappropriate behavior are
quite simply false
now lindsay boylan first brought her
allegations forward about two months ago
on twitter allegations
that the governor denies now she says
she's providing details
as the governor faces separate
accusations of bullying
and creating a toxic workplace i'm
lindsay boylan
lindsey boylan a democrat running for
manhattan borough president previously
worked for new york governor andrew
cuomo
for more than three years boylan alleges
she was told in 2016
the governor had a crush on her she says
once
after a one-on-one briefing cuomo
stepped in front of her and kissed her
on the lips without permission
and on an october 2017 trip on his
taxpayer-funded jet
the governor suggested let's play strip
poker
the governor's office disputes the
claims a statement from four aides who
flew with boylan and the governor that
month
said we were on each of these october
flights and this conversation
did not happen i don't believe their
denials i mean i believe lindsay boylan
democratic new york state senator
alessandra biaggi worked in cuomo's
office from april to december 2017.
i did not like going to work it was
actually one of the darkest moments
and times of my life he has used his
power
in a way to torture people to threaten
people that is a line that you cross
when you behave that way that is abusive
another woman karen hinton worked for
cuomo in 1995
and also describes a culture of
workplace bullying
in the new york daily news hinton wrote
that cuomo made me feel as if i were no
good at my job
and thus totally depended on him to keep
it morgan peckme a journalist
says he received threats from one of
cuomo's top aides
when he wrote an article criticizing the
governor seven years ago
that culture that you describe of
bullying where do you think that came
from
within the office this comes directly
from the top
this is the governor's mo everybody who
covers albany
anybody who works in the orbit of the
capital
knows that the governor is this way and
he thinks it's a virtue
and he's wrong
now these accusations follow recent
revelations that the governor and his
team withheld data about the actual
number of people
who died of coronavirus in nursing homes
in the state of new york
a senior adviser to cuomo says that
state senator biaggi
never interacted with the governor when
she worked for his administration and we
reached out to the governor's office
for a response about biagi hinton and
pet me's claims
and we've yet to hear back tony a few
different issues there for the governor
maul thank you very much